no money
[Applause]
this game requires a Discord server as a
supporting tool I have never
heard of that so
I need to ask you a question
before we get into this
am I having one of those moments where
it's everyone looks like Markiplier
or do I see myself in this creature
imagine me when my hair was like that I
don't know
I know that I'm so egotistical that I
see my name in something and I'm like
I'm starting with episode two because
I downloaded it already and I I don't
know I saw this first episode two came
out like the moment I looked and it was
there and I was just like screw it I'm
gonna do it
and if it's good enough I'll go back and
play episode one or you can play episode
one because it'll be even that more
exciting when you're eager and ready for
it
oh God
hello
ass
oh
I'll take a cup of coffee wow that is
quite a difference
can I have
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway
um uh hello
someone gonna welcome me
so I'm gonna say hi
anybody here to greet me
lovely place I just don't know why I'm
here why is there no one here I'm not
the only one wondering that
I don't know locker room okie dokie then
aha interfloor Transit point
is that an elevator you talking about an
elevator
you using the word elevator oh
this is a lovely locker room except
there's nowhere to sit
your density also leaves something to be
just well
[Music]
fascinating
all right I have that but also why
but in here uh
what
what is that what is cavity
uh okay
hi I'm here to check in I think don't
mind me
hmm
um
and for this I graduated from MIT one
you can't believe it Victoria simulator
is activated
oh what am I training
I don't even
spark no exit allowed you are to pass
through eight words learning seriously
did you think this would impress me
yeah
okay all right I'm down for some
training
doors to open inhale safely with
fingerprints scanners
I mean I kind of figured that out
already just by getting here you didn't
need to you didn't you didn't need to
make a whole room dedicated to this
great job go to the Next Room activate
power in park houses manually if system
malfunctions power stations fuel Doors
Light and endless stores that close the
park
wires both indoors and Outdoors crucial
for successful Duty fulfillment oh come
on
so you're just telling me how to look
around and do things
here Susie is this a new part of the
training
unwanted
care bear gets hacked out for emergency
door unlocking consult Tech Specialists
or buy for app terminals located around
the park
but I already have this because I'm so
smart two more
oh
uh one
Amber's watch open app choose nearest
door need a member's watch contact
Supply Department
aha
door
Susie what's going on
[Laughter]
did I miss that did that happen when I
wasn't looking uh okay
um
all right I'm assuming this is part of
the training the exit Susie damn AI
make sure I see Sparky huh
well don't know about that one but maybe
let's just say maybe
it is synergy Workshop what does that
even mean
wasn't the startup culture is this place
[Music]
uh-huh
okay
well
I don't think I can buy anything
because I don't have any money
because you haven't paid me because it's
training although you should pay me for
training that's like an important thing
okay I can't hack that because I need to
buy another hack
you guys didn't make doors good enough
so that you could just
make them open
all right whatever almost
[Music]
laning
stop complaining oh my God what happened
here hey is anyone alive
anyone alive why would anybody be dead I
didn't even see any blood what are you
talking about hey that's some sweet
money
all right if they don't mind if I just
steal from the other employees do they
oh this is a fun communal employee
shower
I like that oh yay money
yeah
clean oh money
[Applause]
I don't even know what happened
take that
oh my God
good
what
well I wasted that
I thought I thought the toilet paper had
like kissy lipstick stains on him that
would be very weird
that'd be a bizarre thing to have on
toilet paper
but then again it would only be the
second weirdest thing so far in this
place do not feed Sparky
why did you make Sparky you see in the
resemblance
it's gonna you know there's a little bit
yeah yeah yeah I buy the hack I'm gonna
buy a couple
they would never soft locked me out of
like an elevator pass would they
because I'm assuming that's what that is
elevator pass
probably
door
wow sure glad I don't have to do that
with my MIT
hmm
I'm with my MIT degree
money
off
okay
so what was the benefit of being able to
see through this it doesn't exactly help
me
[Music]
what
what's up
sorry I'm busy I'm busy that day
you trying to hint at me trying to give
me a a hint Sparky are you on the other
side of that door
parky go on the other side of that door
better not be on the other side of that
door I gotta tell you that much so why
did I hack that
what was the point of that oh hi what
was the point of that
even the data Synergy works oh
you are in the data Synergy Workshop
and something's behind that door
hack
hack I hacked it good great I'm really
learning boss
I'm really learning
hi
excuse dumb at me
you hearing that alarm
go ahead and learn
so um
you especially configure Tower viewer to
monitor Sparky's location and just tell
our viewer using the hacking app
following the protocol
what
heck the Tower of you is this still
training
am I still being trained
right
I bet I need to put that in the Discord
to be able to understand anything about
the price
well that seems useful
but I guess I can't have that all right
Sparky hold on I'm about to hack your
brains out
depends on the time you spent on
on a monster roaming around the complex
and I'm still testing go to hell Susie
yeah go to hell Susie
I did it Susie where are the Watchers
to transfer marker if unintentionally
acquired never use markers on other
Embrace Park and clothes under any
circumstances
aha okay take marker gun okay can I have
like 20 of them can I have all of them
oh just one all right
uh
wham bam bam
wow you uh you are right there pal
um
sure I'm gonna get freshy oh no I can't
yes I can jump into the pit this road
requiring acceptable physical
preparedness what there's no way I'm
doing this what the hell are they
preparing us for spark is completely
crazy
yeah a little bit I'm I'm confused but
whatever don't tell me twice to jump
into a pit
gun
safety department after breathing
believe me
you will not get off with one complaint
great job go to the Next Room
how many guns do I have
what do I have so many guns
all right I've got well this is dead so
that's nice
not good for anybody all right great
oh boy
this is a lot of systems that they're
putting in here and I don't know why
where's Sparky oh
Susie what the hell all the monsters
must be in mentally shielded boxes being
in an ordinary cage it can easily take
control of me what do you mean how do
you know that oh well here I go
uh
that the shoot shoot Sparky yeah you
know what I'm all right with that who
needs healing when you got damage
dealing get ready Sparky Wham
all right well that's a sweet Miss there
all right Sparky take this this is a
note in the certification protocol I was
against the cruel treatment of the
experimental object but you forced me
[Music]
oh
Susie give the signal another monster
has broken free announce evacuation
immediately you don't have the authority
for such a requirement until death
certification is completed your
admission is I hate you
I hate you I hate you
I hate you Susie
I hate you all right I don't mean to
make fun without the
I was burden into the situation I think
um okay
so I hack you
all right good
and I thank you
and you're out of power too bad I'm not
in a room full of electrical bolts no no
this couldn't be the power room
ah
[Music]
hack buying similar right I got it
hello
I did it
thank you it really is inconvenient
because every time you have to look down
to pick it up you never actually see
this this comes up way too high
why didn't they just let you pick it up
is that supposed to be my flashlight
you're suggesting this Sparky is nearby
is that what you're saying
to me one day the public will find out
about your Dirty deeds in this damn Camp
I swear it's not me then someone else
will shed light on this Terror
wait
Circle
oh
okay I think
[Music]
yes
Sparky
is that you
oh interesting
well
I need another
oh
see I feel like this is just like
exploiting the employee economy to force
us to buy your keys to your own doors I
mean of all the things I think that's
the most questionable thing that I see
occurring here at this moment
so so many lockers
well more guns am I gonna have to shoot
something
[Music]
it's already against me but you Ethan
cut it out we have to stick together
what
what is it what
what happened who was that
what I'm so confused I reported here for
a wonderful employment opportunity did
you shoot this and it opened is that to
teach me oh
future employee briefings oh let's move
to the next part of the birthday
that is Handy that does oh hi oh hi okay
oh this park is uncontrollable State and
unavailable security employees and Park
employee must intervene
you have to focus you have to get back
to your son number
once familiarized proceed to the Next
Room
aha
okay
see am I crazy I'm not crazy right I'm
not crazy
I'm I'm not crazy
you see it right right you see it
is it
okay whatever okay am I still training
preferences of the monster inside party
another indicator for determining the
monster type analyzed spark is using the
chemical gown human food triggers
reactions and secretions preferred
eating spots secluded dark basements
conduct analyzes in the basement these
creatures also love innocent children
for lunch can we talk about this Susie
I'm so confused this is chapter two
is this chapter two
hey all right okay cool ah I'll take one
oh one for me please I'll take a sweets
I hope that was worth it I don't know if
that's what I needed yeah anyway time to
zap someone
I'm gonna see you
I don't know if that's ooze guys guys I
don't know if that's ooze I don't
guys I don't I don't know
exactly does no
hey Flores
come back for us
I've never been in this Wing you
've you've never been here at all you
came here for training right
am I crazy
what are you entry
3476. Dr Bennett is here we're tracking
Sonic anomalies left by the monsters the
patterns are emerging anger apathy fear
sadness all from sound terrifyingly
ingenious now Dr spark our Guiding Light
his genius is the driving force behind
us admittedly he does play favorites
what in the expositional nonsense are
you talking about
what are you talking about the most
horrifying sound
what
does it mean
3498 my new portable sound analyzer is
ready we need to face these sounds to
understand to gain control my colleague
Dr Price he's chasing Shadows or so I
think some runes marks a lamp to see
them is that even productive only time
will tell
only time what did you just I I know
English I do I swear I do I didn't
understand what any of that was
what do I need to buy
of course everyone wants to get The
Nobel Prize so much that they completely
forgot about scientific ethics however
it looks like spark is really close to a
breakthrough a breakthrough of what
what of what
of why for what what do you mean
ah
I I uh I had more hacks I gotta buy more
hacks
I need more
help
okay I have more
Hack That
all right
log entry
3509 the time for testing is at hand
we've isolated some Sonic anomalies in a
secure test chamber if you're hearing
this then it's your job to take the
analyzer and find these anomalies this
is our chance our opportunity to
understand and confront these monsters
their sounds take the analyzer enter the
chamber and listen carefully log your
findings and stay alert and don't worry
about price in his runes the sound is
where the truth lies the real answers
trust in the analyzer trust in the
process and Trust in Dr spark
what process
what rules
what are you talking about another gun
this is a gun Manufacturing
[Music]
the surround
okay I did it I trusted the brothers
only spark doesn't disdain experiments
on people it is a crime to be able to
heal but to continue to destroy
what
wow I overdosed I think
oh man oh man that was too much goo oh I
grew too hard
ah nothing money can't fix
[Music]
1502 price is like a dog with a bone
wasting resources on his Rune Obsession
it's infuriating Dr spark though he's
our anchor our Lighthouse if anyone can
help us tame these monsters it's him Dr
Sparkles you know I'm a Believer I wish
I had someone believe in me as hard as
Dr Bennett believes in Dr spark because
wow this is
you can't you can't buy that kind of
you can't buy that kind of loyalty I'm
gonna ignore that that happened at all
good thing I bought extra hacks
what was the point of that
I don't know if I trusted in the process
hard enough but I definitely trust
inductor spark Brandy
Bennett if only I had a gun
this really is Advanced research you
gotta admit
this is about the runes please tell me
this is the runes I can't I want I I'm
actually excited to hear about Dr
Price's perspective 21-24
human eye but my studies show they're
ever present a sign of possession
perhaps or a warning to their own kind
now about Dr spark the man who fuels our
scientific Pursuits his mind
truly remarkable though I often wonder
why he wastes his time with certain
shall we say less focused colleagues
okay all right I know I was critical but
now I'm starting to get it I love I live
for the Bennett price drama I'm I'm All
About This rivalry I've never wanted
anything more
I I love everything what am I looking at
okay I think I think Rune guy might I
think Rune guy might got it the saw
yeah that's something to this
yeah there's something to do this 2137
perfecting a
uni by the monsters I believe these
runes hold the key to understanding them
to controlling them yeah Dr Bennett on
the other hand obsessed with sound with
noise
you really think these monsters can be
understood through their cacophones
we'll see
yeah we'll see that piece of [__] Dr
Benny doesn't know the first thing about
the complexities of the runic system
this Beast I mean honestly yeah actually
I think you know if I had a judge
between putting my ear up to this thing
and getting my ear up inside that nose
is that a nose up there and looking at
all these runes I gotta be like yeah you
know my money might be on the runes uh I
think I think
I think the ruins might got it there's a
little waveforms going on Dr Bennett
fool
this is Dr Price's official official
papers
that were printed with his name on them
and he uses it to go doctor Bennett fool
ah
this looks important I'm sure that's a
code that's that the boobs dick
definitely code this is a code I'm sure
I could solve this if I look hard enough
which I'm not going to I like that he
made posters to explain how his device
works I hope it's in the form of a gun I
really do think that all problems can be
solved if they are in the form of a gun
I need more hacks
got it
please tell me I get it I get a light
gun
no not a flashlight you fool it's a
light gun it's a gun for light it shoots
light I'm sorry Dr Price but seeing
runes doesn't mean being able to
decipher them and in this matter you are
a real Layman I wouldn't even trust you
to drive a scooter let alone control
monsters
what the frick do you have against Dr
Price
how do you think you learn things you
look at it you study it he [__]
revealed some invisible things you
didn't even know what are you doing you
what kind of doctor are you you went to
MIT
whatever you can't even hack your own
doors You Gotta Buy you gotta buy a hack
tool you're a hack tool oh
uh
play some games and play some games oh
yeah oh yeah oh well
no games
detected potent roon activity in one of
the test Chambers if you're listening to
this you're tasked to investigate it
take my Rune lamp reveal what hides in
plain sight that's our first step to
gain control
go now to the chamber the lamp is
essential don't be swayed by Bennett's
sound theories true understanding lies
in the runes trust in the lamp and in Dr
spark and in Dr Spark all praise Dr
spark that is that is truly where we can
all agree you must don't touch okay you
must believe in Dr spark hmm I don't
know about this room
I came here to develop a cure for all
diseases and as a result I became a
participant in a new Montauk project
as an SCP reference
huh
dude your lamp your your tool your
special tool is a fluorescent lamp
oh boy
did did I get the gun did you give me
the gun man I'm so glad that they
so glad they put the hack store right
next to the door you need it that is
really convenient
I love this game by the way I'm not not
criticizing at all this is amazing I'm
having I'm having the best time
I didn't get the gun
where's the gun
where's the light gun the gun of light
you said
log entry 2141 Bennett
chasing shadows in his Sonic
reverberations I fear he's wasting our
precious resources yet Dr spark trusts
in all our research his wisdom his faith
the one thing that keeps us together in
this chaos oh yeah
the only thing honestly that keeps you
from blasting Dr Bennett with
high-powered light
rmlab
room lamp
I didn't get the gun
yeah
I hear you oh
now what
don't do it
all right you hold on I gotta go get a
lamp uh or a gun did you not give me a
gun did you
I know did I miss it
did I miss it
did I miss him
hey I guess I missed that I don't get a
gun
I deserve a gun but I don't get one I
guess
well that was that was really something
that was
I think it's obvious uh
where this is all gone
very obvious
um
so
[Music]
what about that whole snack thing
is there nothing I was supposed to do
about the snacks oh what are you
what are you
I had a whole doctor
price spiel about a light gun and you're
just gonna give me this gun with no
preamble
[Music]
thank you
is this the work of Dr Sparks genius
he's undeniable
it's Charisma knows no bounds
he truly is the greatest man this went
to no use this is really this really did
not get used uh
into testing actions and acquired
knowledge marker provided for enhanced
simulation you know Susie if one day a
truly Advanced AI appears the first
thing it learns is how to hide how smart
it is
what do you think
nothing
maybe you really are smarter than you
look
special key terminal located in the park
activate them with key light key light
can be found in residential complexes
having a key terminal to load key light
depending on the type of Sparky's
monster
well you didn't teach me how to do the
the goo I don't know how to do what
what
oh what are you talking about what do
you mean what I didn't I didn't learn
any mango
[Music]
get
dude I missed God damn it
hold on you're gonna get
dude
get ready
for the goo
why is it all green
why
didn't you say it was supposed to be
different colors I
uh
what
are you
health
oh that's good
gotta load up you know
oh yeah
okay trampoline house I don't know about
that
whoa
um
so
I need more hacking tools I have no
money
I better bye bye bye
all right a few of these whatever these
I don't know
six yeah
okay all right
all right yeah let's uh let's see this
thing a Wham
oh
[Music]
how about the uh
the terminal database
[Applause]
what the hell
this game throws me off so hard because
in one moment it's like you know
really weird Jank and in the other it's
this incredibly animated and really
actually interesting thing
I'm just so confused
okay uh let me look at him I guess
it's a spin type
I don't know what a spin type
uh hack
did I do it
I did it
all of this goo is green which must mean
it needs sweets
easy
words
yep
what I can have this now
mistake please install the correct key
light to activate the keyboard and
neutralize sparking
mistake please install the correct kill
line to activate the key terminal in
neutralize parking
all right
yes did I pass this stupid certification
Susie what do you think
particularly care about it but Doctors
Park asked me to tell you that he is
ready to put up with any short poundings
of his employees except for one thing
the tendency to the trail I'm sorry what
kind of betrayal what are you talking
about hey Susie don't be silent Susie
oh no no
congratulations
[Music]
duh give me a gun bam I'm out of here
baby
I bet they're Secrets but I'm not going
to get them they're mention my family
you think you scared me tell spark we'll
meet again straight right or left oh
straight yeah left of course son Don't
Be Afraid nothing will happen to Mom
I'll be home very soon ah
sounds like a recording that I would uh
make right before I die a horrible
horrible death
as if I need any of those I have an
elevator pass I have an elevator please
ah
yep
thank you and that's what you're putting
innocent children through
I'll get out
oh get out I'll get out don't worry I'll
get out
in I have nothing
[Music]
I'm so scared everybody
I'm so scared for a reason you can't
comprehend I'm so scared
boom boots oh I was gonna get you and
that's what you're putting innocent
children through don't doubt it spark
I'll get out I'll get out and you will
regret it oh I wish I
whoa oh oh hey get ready to get blasted
[__] oh yeah pick one of these oh
my boy
[Applause]
good thing I trained for this
[Music]
foreign
so
what's my conclusion here
I went into this game just without
understanding that like oh maybe there's
something here and maybe uh I don't know
something reminiscent about it and then
I walk away with an experience more
confusing than I ever could have
imagined
I'm always hesitant to say anything
critical of the games that I play
because I know that everyone who works
on it works very hard and there's some
things that I I truly do think are
impressive the animation and some of the
art style and the assets
and
some of them are really good I wanna I
Wanna Know
what's up with the rest what's up with
them the everything else what's up with
that
and I'm not I'm not mocking any of the
voice acting of course like it's fine
um but
what's up with this game what what's up
with this something's what's up with it
what's up
it's just so confusing why so many guns
what's with the goo
anyway
thank you everybody so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed this I did I
all right a great time it was free so
you know whatever that's that's always
another thing I could fall back on it's
like yeah it's free whatever on Monday
it's good to me it's not bad so thank
you everybody so much for watching
um
Sparky Marky will live on in all of our
hearts I'm sure
uh Link in the description if you want
to play episode one for yourself and
thank you and as always I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye